[Music]
thank you
happy Thursday everybody and welcome to
the data science hangout hope everybody
is having a great week
if we haven't had a chance to meet yet
I'm Rachel it's so nice to meet you
if it is your first time joining us at
the hangout let us know in the chat so
we can all welcome you in as well
this is our open space to chat about
data Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to hear about what's
going on in the world of data across
different Industries so every week we
get to feature a different data science
leader as my co-host here to help lead
our discussion and answer questions from
you all
and so together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everybody I love to hear from everyone
no matter your level of experience or
area of work or background
it's also totally okay to just listen in
if you want there's also three ways to
ask questions and provide your own
perspective on certain topics too
so you can jump in by raising your hand
on Zoom
you could put questions into the zoom
chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to it if you're in a coffee shop or
something or your dog's barking and you
want me to read it instead we also have
a slido link which my colleagues will
share here in the chat in just a second
where you can also ask questions
anonymously
we do share the recordings of each
session each session up to the posit
YouTube and the hangout site so you can
always go back and re-watch or share
with with a friend
but with all that thank you all for for
joining us again this Thursday and thank
you so much art for joining us as the
co-host
art is a private investor and former
chairman CEO and president of
Oppenheimer funds and our I'd love to
kick things off with having you
introduce yourself maybe sharing a bit
about your journey and also something
you like to do outside of work too sure
sure well thanks very much for for
inviting me
I'm uh I'm speaking to you all from uh
New York City where we we have yet to
see winter start supposedly we might get
some snow this weekend but we haven't
had any snow at all this winter so
that's strange I'm sitting here in my
study and I'm drinking out of my GG plot
mug
which was designed by Selena Carter she
graciously let me uh
put this design on what is one of those
sites that lets you print out your own
t-shirts and stuff like that so I had
myself a coffee mug made with that
anyway
um so I'm technically retired I used to
work on Wall Street I was a money
manager for most of my time before I uh
went into a leadership position at
Oppenheimer funds and then I stepped
down when we sold the company to Invesco
back in 2019 uh since then I've involved
in a lot of uh this and that board work
philanthropic work but what I love most
is being a data science hobbyist
uh so I was it you know I started
working with r the language back in 2006
I think it was uh and it just grew from
there and I've just really enjoyed
um you know being able to use it first
in my professional work and then now
more as a as a hobbyist
and really as part of that really
enjoyed uh becoming part of the r
community and you know under you know
really appreciating the joys of of Open
Source software and it's it's power to
it's its ability to put Power into
people's hands to really get good work
done to do good analysis uh you know
like anything else
um you know you can do lousy work
and it's you know it's it's like as
we've seen with chat GPT which speaks
very authoritatively and confidently but
sometimes spews nonsense you know it's
certainly dangerous to put you know
beautiful charts and graphs into
people's hands that tell the wrong story
and I think that's a that's an important
narrative around
um
uh how open source propagates around in
organizations that's a cautionary lesson
but anyway we can we can talk a little
bit about that
um so anyway that's what that's what I
do now you can see my uh my blog at
artstinemets.com where I share my data
science experiments uh and I have to
stress I'm not a data science
professional right I'm a I'm a an
investment professional
uh so I am very much uh an amateur like
with all the caveats that that implies
but again I really enjoy uh hanging out
with smart people like you folks who are
in the main actual data scientists or
actual practitioners uh professionally
um out so you know I Rachel said so what
do you do for for fun or something out
outside of work well again since I'm
retired uh I spend a lot of my time
playing around with r that's while I'm
sitting at my desk I like I I like to
ski I like to hike
uh I'm and uh was a home Brewer I kind
of retired from that when I moved from
New Jersey back into uh New York City
but I can talk at length about uh IPA
recipes if anybody wants to do that
um so
but again one of the things that is nice
about playing around with open source
software is it's not an expensive hobby
you know guys are are famous for uh
spending enormous amounts of Honey of
money to buy gear for their Hobbies
whether it's fishing or cars or or
whatever
um fortunately open source software is
is is whatever I can come up with build
in my head is what I'm what I'm spending
money on so anyway that's uh that's
enough about me I love it I know the
mountains are getting a lot of snow
hopefully this weekend are you gonna
head up skiing yeah well I was in in Big
Sky Montana at the beginning of January
and you know at at 64 years old I
probably shouldn't do the double black
diamonds but I went down one that was
had thin cover and I hooked my armpit
around a tree stump and I tore my peck
so I had orthopedic surgery a couple
weeks ago so I've got to keep uh stay in
a sling for another few weeks but
hopefully I'm gonna get a little late
season skiing in this year when I go
back out and hopefully won't do it again
tear myself up again oh wow
well I hope you're hope you're feeling
okay now
um so I know when we were talking
yesterday a little bit art you were
mentioning your like your journey into
data science started when you became a
little bit frustrated by the limits of
Excel and I'm just curious to hear like
about how that Journey first started and
any tips you have for people who are
also trying to help others in their
organization who'd love to learn too
yeah and the the disclaimer here is is
partly say
it was it was a different time then I
mean a lot of times when we talk about
uh uh uh uh uh
cultural issues uh you know we talk
about well it was different back then
and it was it was different back then
for for data science because back then
employees at my firm could install any
software they pleased on their computer
and that has certainly not true in any
responsible organization today
um but it was a different time so I was
even though you know I could have put in
the the budget request for Matlab uh I I
really
I'm just inherently cheap and so when I
learned about R I was really interested
in that but I I had become frustrated
with the limitations of excel playing
around with uh you know I like
spreadsheet Geeks will do I had these
giant spreadsheets and they had a lot of
VBA macros Visual Basic macros involved
with them but you know they were
increasingly difficult to maintain
uh and I would go back and you know pull
up a project I had worked on several
months earlier and was not able to
figure out what the heck I was doing or
what I was trying to accomplish in that
thing or or if I said well oh I can use
my former work because now this new
project I'm working on is kind of like
that so let me reuse some of my old work
figuring out what I did back then what
former me had done just was a huge pain
in the neck so I was frustrated by that
probably that was probably my biggest
frustration and uh in addition just the
the uh the power of excel when when
working on large data sets uh with lots
of computations
uh was also not you know I was running
up against the limitations there
um so this was and but again this was
just me there was nothing I would say I
was in production for other people to
use I had dashboards with with graphs
and stuff and I would share those around
in meetings but it was really just me so
it wasn't really an Enterprise
application but anyway so I discovered R
and was was hooked immediately
and uh was able to do some some really
cool work but I was an island in the
organization and I think many of us
uh who use open source software may may
feel that way
and
but uh slowly but surely other people
started asking me well how did you do
that or that doesn't look like an Excel
chart or something like that
and at the same time my organization
started becoming
in general more quantitative you know we
were a Oppenheimer was and now as part
of Invesco is a is a
you know a money management firm uh we
manage portfolios of stocks and bonds
and whatever else
the but it's we were uh very much uh old
school fundamental analysis which is
great uh it just isn't doesn't come out
from the quantitative side it's a much
more touchy-feely type of thing
and you know like the rest of the
industry we all started becoming more
interested in uh applying
you know computational power to huge
amounts of information because the price
of computation is going down the
accessibility of huge information was
going up
so it just was part of a natural Trend
and you know I was able to be
um
you know I was more fluent than the
average portfolio manager in my firm
with these with these kind with the
techniques needed to work with that data
because of just my freelance work with r
so I think that that helped me out
um that was not a that was did not play
a part in my career advancement I don't
want to suggest that at all but
I also happen to advance further in uh
in my career at Oppenheimer ultimately
becoming CEO for the last five years of
my of my stay there
um
but you know I I continued to play
around with r even though I have to
admit I was playing hooky from my real
job when I was doing data science work
and you know I would do analysis of our
funds analysis of our competitors funds
on various types of performance metrics
and so forth but you know as CEO that
was not my job there were people I could
ask to do that work for me but that's
that's how I uh you know that was sort
of a release for me and a little bit of
an unwind for for doing that but at the
same time people in my organization
understood that you know I was I was
very sympathetic or receptive to using
these kinds of tools in the organization
and uh and I was constantly evangelizing
about or thinking about ways that our
organization could apply more
quantitative techniques to to upping our
game all across the the business
so you know people the other you know
other other islands around our company
of people who are using this kind of
stuff whether it was r or python or
other tools
and they knew that I was you know very
much a champion of those sorts of things
what that allowed us to do is from their
standpoint practically it allowed them
to to Fast Track
uh permission to use these tools or to
get software updates or things like that
because as I said
you know we all got to the point where
you couldn't just install whatever the
heck you wanted on your computer so at
least they knew that the it guys were
going to be sympathetic to their
requests
um you know and this is a dichotomy I'm
sure many of you see in your
organizations all the time there's an
inherent tension between the high
priests in I.T and the individuals on
their desks who want to be free to use
use these open source tools
and you know having uh leadership in the
organization understand and sympathizing
with that is is very important one of
the great things about posit of course
is that
um
you know posit has has evolved to really
facilitate
uh easing of that tension if you will by
providing you know Walled Garden types
of tools where there can be uh auditing
and control of the versioning of all the
various packages and languages and so
forth that people have on their
computers but also letting people have
access to those tools and and not be
constrained by a large bureaucracy to to
for every little thing they want to use
so I you know I think posit's doing
great work on you know reducing friction
in the Enterprise
so I I like that
um so again we started using these tools
more but here's the the other ironic
thing so I'm an investment person and
like I said I would like to use
quantitative tools to look at time
series of interest rates and stock
prices and correlations and
um uh
uh Capital asset pricing model metrics
around Investments and stuff like that
and
while I was an evangelist for this stuff
the people that were getting more
excited about this were not my fellow
portfolio managers and investment
analysts it was the guys in sales the
people in sales that were getting more
interested in this because
um
like the investment people they were
getting you know uh terabytes of data
um from their uh organizations you know
stuff that would come through our CRM we
used Salesforce or the advisors who
would sell our funds so you know we were
the asset managers and then we would
have advisors who or stock Brokers
financial advisors who would sell it to
retail individuals
and they for a fee would let us see
their customer data what people were
buying what people selling what you know
whether they were buying more growth
stocks or value stocks or whatever it is
and our sales people would find those
tools very valuable but it was a data
dump it was a deluge coming from
different sources a lot of places where
it was unstructured Data uh and even
when it was structured the formats from
Morgan Stanley were different than the
formats from Merrill Lynch and this kind
of stuff but our sales people
you know they got it sooner there are
investment people that we can use
open source data science tools
to make some sense of this
so we did and even today they're they're
the ones that are at at Invesco my
former colleagues at Oppenheimer now at
Invesco are the ones pushing the
envelope on this on the dis the
distribution organization
the one of the things that is a crazy
thing about the mutual fund business is
you know people buy mutual funds and
then they decide to sell them maybe they
need to sell them because they need the
money for other purposes someone dies
and and the money gets distributed in
the estate or the performance stinks and
people stop liking the fund and so they
say they want out all of those things
trigger redemptions
now
um
we are the industry overall has a
background Redemption rate of about 25 a
year that means just to stay even with
how much money we manage we have to go
out and resell 25 of our total asset
base
every year so that's billions and
billions of dollars and the other crazy
thing is well it's not crazy at all but
we sell we pay commissions to sales
people so getting a dollar is much more
expensive than keeping a dollar
so we could drop a lot of money right to
the bottom line if we could cut our
Redemption rate so I sat down with our
sales people that that became kind of a
a thing I was was uh really pounding the
table about so they went and we put
together a data science team of about
nine PhD uh uh data analytics people
and this was all coming out of the sales
budget they they cheerfully uh paid for
all this and we started looking at how
can we reduce our Redemption rate at
that time our Redemption rate was
running above the industry average of
about 27. and the nice thing when you're
a big firm you can run a b tests we try
different kinds of interventions uh
different kind of marketing materials uh
changed how we uh
who we visited and how much time we
spent with people tried so many
different things and we found out what
worked and what didn't work and if
people want some of the details I can go
into that but it's but the bottom line
is that we were able to cut our
Redemption rate in a couple of years
from 27 to 23 percent
so again that was that was uh tens of
millions of of profit dollars that
dropped to the bottom line and again we
were using R and R studio uh to do these
Redemption control tests
um so it was just it was just tremendous
so
um that's amazing I um I remember seeing
the blog post where you you mentioned
that so I want to make sure to go grab
that and put it into the chat for
everybody too
um
but something else I I wanted to ask you
is on the Hangouts we talk a lot about
practices for sharing our work with
Executives yeah and it's rare that we
actually have the executive here on the
call so as a former CEO I was wondering
if you have any tips for all of us on
like communicating with Executives and
sharing our our data work with them yeah
the
um
two key points one is uh you know data
visualization is
the most powerful way to tell get a
narrative across quickly so spend time
learning good visualization techniques
even if you're a math whiz uh and a
coding whiz understand good
visualization it's an aesthetic issue
it's an art and you know there's lots of
there's lots of blogs there's lots of
literature that talk about good
visualization and bad visualization
um and you know don't use a linear scale
when you should be using a log scale you
know stuff simple stuff like that and
because I've seen so many bad charts and
at worst they
you know you're going to lose your
audience very quickly uh
well not necessarily even worse you at
best maybe you're going to lose your
audience at worst your audience will
draw the wrong conclusions and make bad
decisions you know Richard Feynman the
physicist was on the the uh
uh Challenger
uh disaster panel that was the Space
Shuttle that blew up on re-entry and uh
you know his one of the big takeaways in
that uh inquiry was that PowerPoint was
to blame so uh the other the other
point I would make is don't use and I
learned this from uh
uh reading about the history of that
inquest is don't use a PowerPoint
presentation when you should be using a
memo that people would can read in a
narrative because all of you are
familiar with the problem of seeing a
PowerPoint slide so you you've got it
landscape orientation and you've got
this incredible amount of text
on you know 12 point font text filling
up a slide you know as if it's a slide
deck and sometimes you're subjected to
sitting in a conference room having that
thing with with two minutes worth of
text on a slide that you're supposed to
process of course nobody looks at that
at all and you know they're listening to
what hopefully what the speaker is
saying
um but it's it's a complete waste of
everyone's time to create and display
this giant PowerPoint
you know this massive quantity of text
on a PowerPoint slide so don't use
PowerPoint when a pre-read memo would do
the job and yeah some people aren't
going to read the memo
uh but treat your audience with respect
anyway and tell them you're going to
assume
uh people have read the materials uh and
then have your if you're going to have a
PowerPoint or a slide deck
you know have
you know three four bullet points most
on a slide and then have compelling
visualizations that tell tell your story
that's that's gonna
earn you far more respect than showing
that you've crammed your PowerPoint with
a million words
thank you that's really helpful I see um
art or let's see
think Alan you asked the question a
little bit earlier in the chat do you
want to jump in
yeah sure hey everybody
um I I'm curious heart if um in finance
uh or in portfolio management if you
have to to be concerned about things
like uh validated systems uh software
quality the sorts of things we talk
about here a lot with regards to finance
not Finance with um the Pharma and Med
device and stuff are there places in the
business where you've got lots of
landscape to experiment with tools and
then other places where there are folks
doing work that has to have to be much
more diligent about
um you know being validated or being
controlled
um and just because I don't know
anything about it are there like you
know Enterprise applications that are
made for purpose for that specific kind
of stuff or does does every shop have
their own tools that you know
somebody made and everybody just keeps
using them yeah uh good question like
like
um Healthcare uh Finance is a highly
regulated industry you know particularly
as your you know consumer facing so what
we have enormous amounts of regulations
over what we can say to people uh and
what our responsibilities and potential
liabilities are are when we misrepresent
what we are what we are saying to people
like if you say you can't lose money
this is a guaranteed win or something
like that to State the obvious but to
your point yes there is uh a huge
problem in our industry around model
risk and if we use uh any model
and that's very liberally defined by the
way uh to help us with our investment
decision making and we come back at some
point or it's disclosed somehow that
that model had a coding error a bug uh
and gave an incorrect answer because of
a bug in the code
strictly speaking we are liable for
making investors whole for any losses on
that and there have been many instances
of lawsuits around exactly that uh so we
have to be very very careful with and
you know as you all know there's no such
thing as bug-free software there will be
there will be errors and problems
um and it's incumbent on us to
self-report whether or not that caused
losses and the SEC has level leveled
hundreds of millions of dollars of fines
over the last decade to firms with for
model errors and they've been and
invariably
you know there when whenever people lose
a lot of money in an investment that
someone else is managing there will be
lawsuits
so in 2008 there was the great financial
crisis and stocks went down lot
everything went down there were lots of
problems and there were lots of lawsuits
and the Heart of many of those were
I lost money and I'm mad about it I want
somebody to make me whole so now if I'm
hiring a lawyer how do I uh craft a case
that says it was somebody else's fault
other than just the market and I
therefore should be made whole one of
the first things they go looking for
whether or not there were models
involved in making the trades were there
any robots were doing the work and then
were there bugs in that so
um there are uh they're they're every
every model is different every process
is different there's no automated way of
saying
um
is this bug free obviously but we had uh
there are outside all the big accounting
firms will audit your models if you pay
them
so that's what we had to do and
you know between you and me that I don't
think if there was a if there was some
subtle coding error that uh switched a
positive sign to a negative sign
somewhere they're not going to discover
that but nonetheless you can that
becomes a legal defense that you say
well I had an auditor right review the
review the code but it is a it is a huge
issue in the industry
that's really interesting thanks
I want to make sure I go over to some of
the anonymous questions that were asked
too and I just wanted to remind
everybody because I know I say it in the
beginning and a lot of people join after
if you want to ask questions feel free
to raise your hand on on Zoom or you can
put questions into the chat here and
then we also have the slido where you
can ask anonymously and we'll re-share
that link because I know you can't see
it after you've you've joined
um but one of the the first anonymous
questions are was how do we help
leadership say VP level really
understand what it is so that they don't
just succumb to the buzzwords like AI
machine learning big data for example
yeah well you know the buzzwords aren't
useless they to the extent that uh
uh uh a senior leader in the
organization
uh gets all excited about AI
um and was worried about being left
behind then that means they're going to
give you more support for your work
they're going to listen to you and then
you can you know since maybe I'm sitting
in my nice corner office uh and I'm just
hearing the buzzwords I'm like the boss
in Dilbert or something like that and
you can but if I'm willing to listen
then you can give me a deeper
understanding of uh what's involved so I
think the buzzwords are your friend uh
the important thing if I mean if it
creates any sort of urgency or you know
creates more opportunity for uh you know
data scientists to elevate the
visibility of their work the most
important thing though is you have to be
honest so when I as the boss
call you into my office and say I heard
about this chat GPT thing let's fire our
entire you know uh phone our phones uh
customer support people and just turn it
over to chat GPT you have to be honest
about what these things can and can't do
and one of the things that
this will never change this has been
true since the times of Hammurabi that
um
you know subordinates will come into the
boss's office and they'll blow Sunshine
up your skirt and you know avoiding that
getting getting an environment this is
and this is important this is what the
bosses have to do what the leaders have
to do is create uh an environment of
trust where people can deliver bad news
about what something can and cannot
accomplish
uh to the boss and they can't be afraid
of saying you know sorry boss you know
chat GPT isn't the be-all and end-all
um
and you know I mean again I experienced
this firsthand but you know people if
you if I would say oh this sounds like
fun let's do it or this that looks like
this will be interesting let's do it
people will start scrambling around and
try and do it because the boss likes it
um and Well on one sense I'll say good
because I'm the boss I'd like to have
some influence over what people do but
it's but you you have to have the
courage to say no this is not going to
work if it's not going to work
thank you I I really like that reframing
of like buzzwords can be your friend as
well when you're trying to get get your
point across or highlight your words
yeah
um Dave I see you you had asked a
question a bit earlier too do you want
to jump in next
Church thanks Rachel
hi art uh this is Dave Shea from posit
um the the description you have of your
experience at Oppenheimer I know is
almost backwards for a lot of financial
firms and definitely for other big
organizations you know this is data
science excellence and opportunity
pushed from the top down
um a couple questions around that have
you had any success in uh discussing
with your CEO peers and this opportunity
and have you won them over to that and
then on the other side for
folks you know working up the chain what
do you think is is a successful way to
convey that I that opportunity upward
yeah well you know I think the like I
said yeah
it was a different time then but the
world has come around to understanding
the power of Big Data again it's a
buzzword right Big Data uh data science
and my alma mater Denison University has
launched a whole school around data
science data analytics and it's a
liberal arts college I was a Russian
major in college and
um but I I think CEOs today very much
even if they don't necessarily
understand it that going back to the
buzzwords they think it's important and
they need to pay attention to it uh so I
don't see much resistance to that you
know it's funny though like I said the
investment people in my organization
to some extent still are very old school
they are very wary of quantitative
techniques because they you know there
are many Quant funds out there and some
of them are you know do great work
there we are fundamental investors so
it's reading annual reports and talking
to management visiting the factories or
whatever it happens to be that's
fundamental management we try to beat
the market doing better research in that
in those lines and there was a lot of
resistance to
quantitative techniques because
we're fundamental we don't want that
we're not going to let the robots take
over now the argument I would make I did
make to you know when I became Chief
investment officer and then CEO the
argument I would make to the uh
investment people and I I was not going
to push anything down their throats I
was trying to evangelize to make them
want to do this
but I said to them look this isn't about
the robots taking your jobs or we're
gonna we're gonna you know I mean
literally that's what they were worried
about
that we were just going to make these
Quant funds because we had some we
launched because they would nobody would
come around on the fundamental side we
launched some Quant funds uh the
um
the argument I made with limited success
was look I'm not talking about getting
rid of you I'm saying you have been
digging ditches with the shovel
your whole career now I come and give
you a backhoe you're not going to use it
you know it's a force multiplier if you
can apply these quantitative tools to
suddenly process far more data than you
used to be able to it's it's making your
analyst far more efficient
uh
but you know inter like I said in terms
of the rest other CEOs other people in
in Asset Management it's everyone's come
around I think to that and you know how
do you get so I I mean I would be
interested in hearing what other people
say about this because you folks are
more mid-career early career than than I
certainly am as retired you would
probably have a better sense of the
receptivity in your organization to
using more powerful quantitative tools
few people resonated with when you said
living on your own Island so a lot of
people were feeling that too
you know what I hope and this again this
worked to some extent in my organization
and it's it's happening right now at
Invesco too I should add people look
over your shoulder and say wow that is
cool how do you do that or I see
a way I could apply what you're doing
there so for instance an Invesco right
now this and this this started after I
had left they they one of their folks
again in sales uh has created a shiny
app
that
um
if one of our customers which is to say
are Brokers shares their customers which
is the end investor their portfolios
with us what other funds they're
invested in what other stocks are
invested in whatever we can run uh an
analysis on that to help them optimize
uh their tax situation when they should
take capital gains when they should take
Capital losses what they should sell to
realize a loss or a gain and then what
they if they want to keep the portfolio
complexion the same what should they
then buy on the other side to to keep
the portfolio complexion the overall
risk or or aggressiveness whatever it
happens to be the overall portfolio
complexion the same so he built a shiny
app that does that so all of our sales
people all of Invesco sales people can
look at all of the advisors that they
serve and look at that and that
generates discussions and sales people
love to have opportunities to call their
customers up and have a interesting
discussion and say look here's an issue
you have that I think I can help you
solve that's sales people love getting
that kind of a lead so it generates that
sort of thing and then if the discussion
goes further with one click they
generate a detailed PDF report on
exactly what the what the
uh what the gains and losses are across
the portfolio and the sales people just
love that tool but it's one individual
and you know my fear is that it dies
with him if he leaves the firm who's
going to maintain that you know it's
it's an island and yet the it's it's a
shiny app in production that has become
a a extremely popular tool
among 200 Sales people
so it's uh it's it's an interesting uh
you know it's an interesting opportunity
you know and I've tried to incr and this
this person is not naturally a real
outgoing gregarious uh individual
you know so I've uh been trying to
encourage him to think about ways that
he can uh let other people know this is
a tool that he built and you can have
this kind of a cool tool also if you
know in your in your area so yeah
getting him off the island is I made it
a uh uh
you know I have no vested interest in
this I kind of made my mission
absolutely it's really interesting to
think about like maybe some of us could
be targeting our work to different
groups of people within the company like
sales which we may not have thought of
before and I see somebody had asked an
anonymous question that
that sales was so interested in the data
was really interesting to them and they
asked were there any groups that you
were surprised weren't interested and
why do you think that was yeah well
again I've already told a story about
the investment people yeah and and they
were they were pretty skeptical the
other the other group as well
you know is it is it worth worth the
cost uh what's the irr on this
investment and you know again in the in
the anecdote I said I shared about
Redemption control it the irr was
strongly positive but it's not it's not
always going to be that way but I think
it is important to have a clear-eyed
understanding of
what the irr is going to be on on a
project like this uh what I would not be
concerned about is whether there are
enough projects for a data science team
and most organizations
um
you know you might have a particular use
case when you spin up some kind of a
data science organization but like I
said very quickly other people will see
the cool stuff that is being that is
happening and want in on it
uh
oh what one of the the questions I saw
going back into the chat was you know
what books you might recommend that uh
help you throughout your career to
develop your mindset as a data science
CEO well let's see here
um I already talked about
tufty right so
he's got a whole bunch of books but this
is this is the one that started it all
the
visual just I got this game The Vision I
can see it my state of information
and this guy is kind of a lovable
curmudgeon kind of a crank but he's
passionate about making sure that your
visualizations convey the information
that you want them to convey so
theories of books they're all they're
all classics in the uh
in the field
um the another one Michelle that I think
is a ripping yarn is Against The Gods by
Peter Bernstein the remarkable story of
risk for anyone who wants to understand
how we we went from uh thinking
everything is just in the hands of the
Gods and it's all fate to uh being able
to price derivatives uh using you know
normal distributions and understanding
probability this is a great book and
this is not dry in the least but I think
it's very useful for understanding how
the history of risk evolved you know the
the ancient Romans were in veteran
gamble gamblers but they had no sense of
probability so if if you wanted to go
play cards play poker with the Romans
you could really fleece them
um but it was it was Blaze Pascal
who uh who was a philosopher and
mathematician who really developed
probability and he was and he did it
because he was a he was a gambler
um so
you know there is uh
there's another book that got me
thinking about it's Out Of Reach because
it's over in my business books section
um but there's another book called The
Outsiders by
Richard those last name is Thorndike uh
I'm not sure his first name it is
Richard but he has a a great book for
thinking about
how CEOs can should think about
maximizing the value of their businesses
um and that had a profound influence on
me one of the things that is true if you
look at most mergers of publicly traded
companies the vast majority
uh three plus three equals five
which is to say that the mergers are
usually destructive of shareholder value
and
um I I won't name names but I I've
experienced this so often in my career
and
the problem is the CEO of the combined
entity now gets to say I grew the
company it's much bigger now and he of
course he or she
um obviously usually a white man uh is
uh running a much bigger organization
and that could be used to justify the
board paying them a lot more generous
compensation and he gets the reputation
as a deal maker
uh but the problem is if the company if
the two companies were worth six apart
and they're now worth five
you lost money you didn't do a good job
this book The Outsiders really cracks
that open and does a lot of as business
books like to do there's a lot of
anecdotes and case studies uh shows a
few CEOs who understood that and bucked
that Trend and really thought about how
to uh
grow the wealth of their of their uh of
their shareholders which is what they're
accountable to
um you know one of the things one of the
uh
one of the things that uh whenever
companies get mashed together there's
talk of cost savings right you have
synergies economies of scale Etc and
that's all well and good but there's
hardly hardly ever any talk about
Revenue synergies because there's seldom
RNA even though there will be some some
uh genuflecting in that direction so you
know that anyway that book I thought was
uh very formative in my thinking as
someone who was running a company
someone who bought other companies and
who ultimately sold my company to
another company
I love this just grabbing the books off
the back it's like book club with art
here I think this is I I I'm a book I I
have a fetish book I fetishize them as
as objects
and so I I really like sitting in my
library with a Manhattan in the evening
and reading a book
nice so I know something
that you are also really involved with
is like enhancing uh data literacy and
mathematical literacy
um and you've been involved with rock
the street wall Street's mission is to
equip girls for the skills to succeed
um and many other organizations and I
wanted to give some time to talk a
little bit about that too and see if
there's anything that you'd recommend we
get involved in or ways to to get more
involved yeah thanks for asking that
because it's it's
it's obviously a worthwhile topic I
don't have to sell anybody here on on
the value of being data literate or
understanding basic math
um but you know there's a there's a
weird
cultural problem I think we have
certainly in this country and maybe in a
lot of other countries is that it's it's
okay to be bad at math people are
perfectly
prop happy maybe even proud to say oh
I'm bad at math oh you know it's like no
no one says oh I'm bad at reading you
know oh I'm proud to be illiterate
um
numeracy should be something that we all
are very proud of having and the
consequences of
not being numerate are horrible and you
see you know in you know our our country
has become so polarized politically and
you know the the rhetoric that goes back
and forth so much of it is is
grounded on
so much of the persuasive power of that
is grounded on people not understanding
numbers I find
um and not being willing to and being
very skeptical of science being very
skeptical of experts uh like that's
those are Elites or something like that
when you know all of you probably went
to college and you learn a lot of stuff
and you went on to graduate school or or
in your careers and you're very proud of
being an expert in your field and all
the knowledge you've created and the
idea that there just should be devalued
somehow because people need to be feel
good about being ignorant is an
unfortunate State of Affairs I wish we
could uh get back to a point where
knowledge is is respected in whatever
field that happens to be but certainly
one of the ways to to do that and make
all of us more successful in our own
lives is to make sure that
uh kids understand
you know know that it's it's cool it's
too strong a word but cool to know math
and be proud of having math skills
and so you know I'm I was involved with
the uh national museum of mathematics
which their mission is to make math cool
and it's not a kids museum by the way
they they have tons of kids programs uh
and probably most of the visitors to the
museum are children but you know it it
really shares The Wonder of mathematical
Concepts uh at an adult level as well so
it's if you're ever in Manhattan it's
it's absolutely worth a visit because
it's it's a very cool Exploratorium kind
of Museum it's just not you know
definite integrals printed on a poster
on the wall or something it's a very
cool Museum and you know the the one of
the problems is in obviously in in
um or communities underprivileged
communities whatever word you would like
to describe them uh uh minority
communities they're you know the schools
are generally poor and rock the street
Wall Street brings uh
a finance curriculum into
underserved schools and using them using
uh using volunteers so the the business
model if you will rock the street is we
get a corporate sponsor and a corporate
volunteer from that sponsor and they
teach a
uh call it a finance course to to kids
and one of the things purposes of that
is to get more girls because it is is uh
focused on on girls and I use the word
girls because this is high school
um get girls interested in careers and
financial services and while we know
less than half of the girls are gonna
actually go into financial services but
every single one of them is going to get
out of this program with basic financial
literacy they are going to understand
that the credit limit on your MasterCard
isn't an asset and you know paying 25
percent a year in compound interest on
your credit card balance is a really bad
problem to get into so you know those
kind of basic issues around uh life's
Financial life skills or is an important
part of what they do and of course they
go into these less served communities
and one of the things that just like
breaks my heart and why I'm passionate
about this is you know you know you've
all heard this this term the cycle of
poverty and there's this cycle of
ignorance exists in these communities as
well and in many cases
um you know obviously the the family
situation is not a traditional uh
two-parent family and even when it is
you have issues where there isn't
respect for learning in some of these
families they say why do you want that's
not for you you don't have a chance you
know the system is rigged against you
um
why bother and you know fighting against
a familial culture in some cases to give
these girls the belief that yes you can
achieve you that doesn't mean the road
is easy but this is possible and it just
takes
hard work and learning and you can
achieve that and so rock the street does
does great work you know swimming
against that that tide of ignorance so
it's it's been
um heartbreaking and to see some of this
stuff but also so inspiring to see what
what the change that it can make in some
kids lives so you know helping other you
know whatever it happens to be in
uh helping kids uh
understand early on that they can
achieve that learning and knowledge are
valuable things to have it seems crazy
to have to say that but you know girls
in particular are underrepresented or
women in particular are very
underrepresented in Asset Management so
that was one of the things that got me
interested in rock the street to begin
with uh we need lots we need lots more
representation among people of color as
well but women also are again very
underrepresented so that's just trying
to get a little more inclusivity in
finance but also what rock the street in
particular recognize is that girls
self-select out of stem Fields very
early
they're the cultural background is such
that women are told explicitly or
implicitly girls are told explicitly or
implicitly that they're not good at math
they're not good at science or that's
not for them
and again it doesn't have to be explicit
but we find that they self-select out of
stem very early in high school and
that's why it's important to you know
there's lots of groups that help give
women early career support for in
college there's girls who code for
instance that's more college level
getting down into the high school level
is is critical because of this problem
absolutely thank you so much for sharing
that and I I did put into the chat if
there are other groups that people are
involved with as well and want to share
in the chat please do
um I know that our time goes by so
quickly here is okay if I like rapid
fire a few questions that you are thank
you for listening to me blab folks
we love it
um so one anonymous question and it
maybe touches on things we've talked
about but can you say like what's the
number one reason you think
whether it's Financial Services or any
company should move to open source
languages like R and python
yeah because of the the ecosystem uh you
know with r or python is the packages
that will do anything you want and it's
and these packages of course are
constantly peer reviewed there was a
there was a uh
there was a notion 10 15 years ago that
commercial software was better because
you had people who were paid to mind it
whereas open source anybody could do
anything and they could who knows
whether the code is any good
which the truth was the opposite of that
right when you've got a million eyes on
something errors are much are spotted
much more quickly now there were there
were commercial software firms that had
a vested interest in perpetuating that
that notion
there was oh there was a blog post it
was taken down at I guess it was SAS uh
where they were ripping open source code
and they they made a very uh
uh kind of disgusting dig uh that could
at Hadley Wickham they said do you know
do you want trained professionals
auditing your code or do you want some
drunk guy in New Zealand
which I I thought could only mean hardly
that that that Hadley's from New Zealand
I have no idea whether he enjoys liquor
at all but why would they say that it's
ridiculous
um but you know it just shows the
nastiness that was out there but it's
clear that the divert the the huge
ecosystem of packages maintained by
passionate individuals acting as a
community is what gives open sources
power
never saw that blog post but now I'm
interested to go okay
one other
um anonymous question was as a data
person what are the best ways to develop
domain and business knowledge they said
it benefits me to talk with the business
people but not systematically
yeah that's that's a uh you know kind of
a tough problem because it requires you
being uh an advocate for yourself in the
organization and not all of us are
equipped to do that I wasn't
my path to the to the top of the
organization was was very serendipitous
and I'll I'll spare you the details on
that as well but you know you need to be
able to get out there and advocate for
yourself so you you have to show up and
stick your nose in
uh when there are discussions about
the the business
uh and you know hopefully you can you
can
um
you know present yourself as someone who
is you know eager to help solve problems
if you know if you say look I'm here
because I want to understand the problem
so I can do better helping you you know
however you want to say that I mean
that's the kind of approach that always
worked with me when when people say you
know because I certainly could have no
objection to someone who's say an I.T
coming around saying I want to
understand how you run money better so I
can understand your needs better No
One's Gonna
no one's going to say oh get out of my
face
but but it does require you getting out
of your your comfort zone perhaps and
being an advocate for yourself
definitely I just want to make sure I
had seen everybody's questions so feel
free to raise your hand here
and are if you have to run at the top
for the hour
just let us know I just want to give
people a last second okay I'm gonna go
nuke my Ramen when you're uh okay
okay so one question I
did want to ask you before you go is
what is the best career advice that
you've ever received
you see I'm not sure I I could say what
the best advice is it doesn't have to be
best maybe just something that comes to
mind I I don't like using the word best
actually when I think about it
um
you know it was
you know just
you know don't look
to your career advancement yes you might
be an ambitious person but don't think
about everything in terms of how is this
going to advance my career think in
terms of how this will help others in
their career it's kind of enlightened
altruism if you will because if you gain
a reputation in your organization for
someone who is boosting others
that is going to grease the skids for
you in a in a very powerful way someone
told me that once and it was
absolutely true
you know because because no one likes
that guy who you know he's already
looking for his next job
well thank you thank you so much
everybody for all the great questions so
thank you so much art for for joining us
here this has been a blast it was a lot
of fun I appreciate it hope I hope the
rest of you enjoyed it as well
thank you so much I'm going to share
your LinkedIn here in the chat so people
know where to find you
um anything else you want to leave us
with is uh art steinmets.com
awesome I'm going to re-share that again
in the chat too here we go thank you so
much art have a great rest of the day
everybody